c'est demain que la cour de cassation
doit trancher dans la sphère dils elle
se prononcera en effet sur la demande de
révision de la condamnation de patrick
dils
cet homme condamné à perpétuité en 1989
pour le meurtre de deux enfants en
moselle
la cour se basera sur un élément nouveau
permettant de suspecter le tueur en
série francis heaulme le rappel des
faits avec estelle mathieu et itv nerfs
dans sa prison de toul patrie 10 31 ans
aujourd'hui attend ce jour là depuis 14
ans demain après plusieurs années de
réflexion après de nombreuses
investigations et un supplément
d'information la justice française se
prononcera sur son sort patrick geeks le
plus jeune condamné de france à la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
c'était en 1989 en lorraine il avait 17
ans patrick dils reconnu coupable d'un
double homicide le meurtre de cyril et
alexandre les faits se sont déroulés ici
sur ce talus le long d'une voie ferrée à
montigny les metz en moselle patrick
dils après des aveux détaillés crie son
innocence dès les premières semaines
après son incarcération pour la
quatrième fois les familles voisines
autrefois se retrouvant ici dans la
chambre criminelle de la cour de
cassation face à face liés par un fait
divers sordide
au début on n'a pas compris ce qui nous
arrivait après on nage et analyser tout
ça et puis je me suis dit faut pas
laisser un innocent en prison il faut se
battre et ça fait maintenant 14 ans
qu'on se bat et puis je regrette pas du
tout d'avoir battu comme ça parce que
maintenant la vérité leur train
d'éclater
je suis partagé dans ses sentiments je
comprends d'un côté que l'on puisse
faire des recours puis de l'autre j'ai
envie de dire stop
il faut maintenant que les familles
space d'oc deuil qu'on les laisse en
paix que on envisage le problème d'une
autre manière que celle de la révision
guinot sens
la cour de révision doit se prononcer
sur l'existence d'un élément nouveau de
nature à faire naître un doute sur la
culpabilité de patrie ni l'élément
nouveau c'est lui francis heaulme un
tueur en série déjà condamné par la
justice française avec ses déclarations
recueillies par l'adjudant abgrall avec
ce dessin très précis les lieux du crime
francis heaulme eux reconnaît que ce
jour là il est bien passé à cet endroit
cette présence sera t elle suffisante
pour prouver l'innocence de 10 c'est
toute la question
depuis plusieurs témoins se sont
manifestés l'ancien commandant de police
au maire stragier pas vieille dame lui
avait parlé d'un vieux monsieur avait le
david ehrlich n'avait vu un adulte
suivre les enfants
depuis il a reconnu francis troy ce
jeune homme qui le jour du crime s'était
retrouvé nez à nez avec un individu au
t-shirt éclaboussé de sang et puis
récemment l' enquête de la gendarmerie
de metz révélait que la semaine du crime
francis heaulme eux travaillaient à
proximité des lignes au regard de tous
ces éléments
la justice doit maintenant choisir
ordonné un nouveau supplément
d'information ou de rejeter le pourvoi
ou cassé l'arrêt keane lapointe d'année
coup ordonné un nouveau procès si
c'était le cas patrick 10e redeviendrait
présumé innocent et pourrait être libéré
aussi tôt ce serait une première dans
l'histoire judiciaire